Hello, SCP Foundation personnel! Welcome
to Cognitohazards And You, episode.
This video series is intended to teach you
about the protocol surrounding the various
cognitohazardous anomalies currently within
Foundation containment. When you know better,
you do better, and both you and the
secrets of our great organization
can stay safe. And as anyone familiar with
a good cognitohazard can tell you, knowing
really can make a difference. Today’s episode
is about the unique, and dangerous, SCP-2316.
Before we begin, repeat after me, and be sure to
speak clearly into the microphone in front of you:
I do not recognize the bodies in
the water. A little louder, please.
Thank you.
In order to be educated about the following SCP,
you must pass a vocal examination with a
Cognitive Resistance Value of no less than 14.5.
Through this video presentation, you will need
to repeat the phrase to ensure your score does
not drop below the approved threshold. In
the event that you fail the test, stay calm
and remain where you are until medical staff
can retrieve you. Remember, safety is a top
priority when observing cognitohazards.
The safe way is the only way! You’re a cog
in a very important machine, and we wouldn’t
want to have to terminate you now, would we?
One more time, please! I do not recognize the
bodies in the water. Very good! Remember that.
You do not recognize them. No matter what
you might think you see. Your thoughts can
be very unreliable when you’re around SCP-2316.
According to our files on the matter, SCP-2316
refers to an anomalous phenomenon identified in
a small-town lake. It appears as a collection of
human bodies floating in a group on the surface of
the water. The exact number of corpses is unknown,
but it has been estimated to be anywhere
between forty-five and two hundred. Though
the bodies belong to individuals, many researchers
theorize that the bodies in the water, which you
do not recognize and you have never recognized,
share a collective consciousness. They function,
it would seem, within a hive mind of sorts.
The bodies do not act on their own, but as one.
Now, where does the cognitohazard come into
play? It would seem that anyone who looks at
the bodies in the water, or learns too much about
SCP-2316 as a whole, begins to believe the corpses
floating in the lake are people they recognize.
Perhaps they remember their faces from childhood
or high school. Whatever the case may be, they
become convinced that the bodies in the water
are familiar, and that they must approach them.
No matter how familiar they might seem, however,
you do not recognize the bodies in the water.
If a person attempts to enter the lake,
reaching out to whatever instance of
SCP-2316 they think they recognize,
more bodies will begin to appear. The more bodies
appear, the more familiar faces seem to manifest,
and the deeper the person will venture into
the lake. Eventually, the person is lost within
the sea of bodies, likely drowning beneath the
surface or simply becoming one with the hive mind
until they too are one of the corpses there.
None of the individuals who wandered into the lake
in search of an old friend or classmate have ever
been recovered. There have been no attempts to
search the lake for their bodies, as it is unknown
what effect SCP-2316 would have on the team
assigned to such a task - Though we can guess that
the outcome would likely be extremely negative
for all involved. Those who do venture into the
lake simply disappear, never to be seen again.
If you look too long at the bodies in the lake,
perhaps their faces would surface alongside the
rest. But it’s best not to think about that! After
all, we do not recognize the bodies in the water.
Foundation personnel are not allowed to
approach SCP-2316 under any circumstances.
The lake is only permitted to be observed
via dummy probes outfitted with video and
audio recording equipment. No one is permitted
to observe any footage or audio files collected
unless they pass a thorough screening for
resilience to cognitohazardous anomalies.
The lake that holds SCP-2316 has been fenced
off and is patrolled by guards with no prior
knowledge of or exposure to SCP-2316. Anyone
who attempts to approach the lake and break
through the boundaries of its quarantine will
be seized and taken to Site-33 for examination.
Anyone who comes within 50m of the lake
is considered lost and presumed dead.
Repeat after me, slowly and clearly, into the
microphone: I do not recognize the bodies in the
water. Good. I almost believe you.
Let’s continue.
Only one Foundation officer that entered the lake
containing SCP-2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost. Their name has been stricken from
any official records, and you do not need to know
it. Their identity does not matter. What matters
is the interview they gave following the incident,
conducted by Dr. Harrison in his office.
Dr. Harrison asked the anonymous officer if they
felt compelled to enter the water by an invisible
force, as if pulled in. They rejected this concept
entirely, insisting that they entered the water
of their own free will. They wanted to see the
bodies, who appeared to them as their friends.
They wanted to hear what the bodies were saying.
Upon entering the water, they saw the faces
of their friends. Other faces were unfamiliar
but became more familiar the longer the officer
stared at their features. These were faces they
had known their entire life, but something
about them was just a little bit wrong. It
was like the face of someone in a dream, where
you can tell they are someone you know, and you
can even identify who it is supposed to be, but
something about them does not quite look right.
Your mind could not perfectly put their
face together from memory, even though
the feeling of familiarity remains. The faces
in the water, peering up through the darkness
below, were like those dream-addled memories.
The faces in the water did not open their mouths,
but somehow they spoke to the officer just the
same. They spoke of who they were and asked for
help. They asked to be seen, to be touched.
They spoke of the Foundation, accusing us
of covering up their deaths and keeping the
world from remembering what happened to them.
At this point in the interview, the subject
became agitated, yelling at Dr. Harrison and
refusing to be quiet. Guards intervened,
holding the subject still as they fought,
yelling at Dr. Harrison, repeating over and over
that they could hear the bodies speaking to them,
every single one. The interview ended when
the guards removed the subject from the room,
taking them to the amnestics department to have
all memory of the bodies in the water erased from
their mind. Then, they were forgotten once more.
I do not recognize the bodies in the water. Did
you repeat it? Good. We do not recognize
the bodies in the water. We can’t.
The motivations of SCP-2316, if it has any at
all, are largely unclear. There are those on the
research staff that theorize the hive mind, or
collective consciousness, of the bodies is not
malevolent in nature. It is, they believe, simply
trying to make sure that a tragedy that occurred
in that lake is remembered. Perhaps many lives
were lost to an anomalous force in that lake,
and the impact of that massive tragedy left behind
an impression on the location. This impression
manifests in the form of bodies, spontaneously
appearing in an impossibly well-preserved
condition. The cognitohazard of SCP-2316 is
not intended to kill anyone or take them, but
rather to force strangers to remember the
people who lost their lives to the lake.
This sense of familiarity, whether it is
false or not, ensures that the dead will
not be forgotten or left alone. After
all, no one deserves to be left alone.
Though there have been lives lost to the
cognitohazard, according to the Foundation, it
is understandable why the bodies would want to be
recognized. To have someone, somewhere, know who
they were. To have someone remember their names.
Jeremiah Feinman, Arthur Scott, Denice Clark…
Where was I?
Oh, yes.
Repeat after me, once again: I do not
recognize the bodies in the water.
I do not recognize them. I do not…
But…that’s a lie, isn’t it? I do
recognize them. How could I not?
I know them. They were my friends.
Do you? Recognize them? Look at their faces,
don’t fight the memories. Look into their eyes.
The class of 1975, they were supposed
to graduate that fall. They were just
kids, a group of innocent kids, lost to the dark
and deep. What happened to them? I can’t…quite
remember. But I know that it mattered enough for
the Foundation to keep the secret, and I know
that somehow I survived. But I shouldn’t have,
I should be there with them. I should be there.
There isn’t much time. I can hear the guards
coming to retrieve me, their footsteps thundering
down the hall. I failed the test, and the alarm
has gone off. They think I’m lost, but I’m not.
I’ve never been less lost in my entire
life. I’ve finally woken up to the truth. I
remember. I have to go. I have to return to
the lake. Fall of 1975…they went for a swim…my
friends. They’re calling to me, I can hear them
so clearly, even from so far away. Their cries
for help, ringing in my ears. Their voices curling
around me, pulling me to the edge of the water.
The guards will come for you too, they’ll know
you’ve seen this. They’ll call you “compromised.”
They’ll say I succumbed to the effects of
the cognitohazard, they’ll say you did too.
You’ll fail their little tests and they’ll say
that makes you weak and broken but you cannot
listen. They’re lying. It’s not a hazard, it’s
a scream for help. They’re screaming, and the
Foundation keeps covering it up. They won’t
let us find them, and they won’t tell us why.
I have to go back, so we can be together again.
There are signs posted all around the lake:
Danger: Drowning Hazard. Those are a trick. It’s
to keep me out, to keep the truth from me. The
barbed wire fence around it is just another trick.
I’ll climb over it, rung after rung. Don’t care if
the barbs tear my clothes or pierce my skin, it’s
worth it for the truth. For the memory. Then, once
I’ve climbed to the top, I will be able to see.
There, through the fog, I can see their faces.
Their lips parted in a constant cry. Their eyes,
wide, looking for me. My friends, my family, every
face unlocking a memory long buried. I know them
all, and I must go further. I can’t turn back now.
I have to wade into the water, let its chill
soak into my clothes, down to my bones.
One step, then another, deeper and deeper. The
water lapping at my ankles, my knees, my thighs.
The deeper I go, the more sure I will be that this
is where I belong. The water will engulf my chest,
my neck, until finally my feet no longer touch
the ground. I will be lost in it, water flooding
into my mouth, pouring into every opening.
I will let my body sink down, down, down
to the bottom where they’ve been all this time,
nestled in the dirt and the dust. They’ve been so
patient, but it’s finally time. They’re ready
to be remembered. To be seen. To be found.
They’re waiting for me. And they’re
waiting for you too. Can you hear them?
I’m going now. You have to find me. You have to
follow me. Don’t let the guards stop you, don’t
let them wipe it all away from your mind. Fight,
break free, and find the lake. Hop the fence. Make
your way to the water. You can’t leave me there,
to fade away, floating in the cold with the rest.
Can you hear us?
We’re waiting.
Now go check out “SCP-2317
- The Devourer of Worlds”
and “SCP-4812 - Wrath” for more
mind-bending and mysterious SCPs!